what's happening there reject nation
greg john squad leader ace follow him on
instagram and twitter our star wars
expert has he self proclaims on the
daily to his mom and dad you pervert
anyway guys we're gonna watch star wars
part five of obi-wan kenobi i don't care
what a small percentage that sounds like
a large percentage of the internet has
to say i'm very much excited for this
it's probably acknowledge the fact that
we have microphones we have a headphones
in the mail right now with the headset
they're supposed to come today but
they're coming late so this is the next
best thing that uh johnny boy over here
was able to jerry-rig at the last minute
but yeah we want to improve the audio
for ourselves we figured after a million
subscribers we should probably get good
audio for these reactions and now here
we are so if you guys can leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated also
subscribe and click that bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next
episode the final episode of obi-wan is
up here on the channel as always
following the watch long story single
with the time code for ob1 available for
our super sexy rejects at our patreon
page that makes them really catch on
losing my breath and yeah a couple bunch
of shows over there as well lastly i
want to thank storyblocks for uh
sponsoring this video let's get to it
oh
looks like the prequels this is
coruscant
oh
we are all ready let's do some de-aging
oh there you are
i was beginning to think you weren't
coming then maybe i stand more of a
chance this time are you ready
oh
yeah this is uh clone wars era attacking
the clones era then let's begin oh my
god
oh my god i'm already losing my mind
this might be the episode oh
you got to go back vader keep
flashbacking back to tank vader
oh my god
where is he
the tracker worked
he's arriving on jabim as we speak
you have done well
huh
some people on the internet have
opinions
oh damn we've been nailed right
cool vader's woke the grand inquisitor
the hand of the vader
set a course captain
we leave for jabim at once oh yeah
is the grand inquisitor actually dead no
definitely
rebels
always canon what are you doing here
right after i saw you i got into a fight
with that scary lady inquisitor
now i'm wanted by the empire but now i
know what it feels like being a real
jedi
same thing him that transport i need to
get her back to alderaan
once we get all these people out of here
i'll do whatever you want they've been
waiting for months we used to know a
trade route to get them out but the
windows closing we held it to help you
get the kid
we only have a few hours that's good
cause you don't have much time yeah you
got the hell out of here
really cool
the light will fade
but it's never forgotten
oh damn wow
um what's happening the controls aren't
responding the imperial destroyer just
arrived in orbit above us she must have
tracked us it's not her it's fader he'll
attack next he hasn't the patience for
siege how do you know
[Music]
mercy doesn't defeat an enemy master
[Music]
hmm
just stay there i can't get over
how
good hayden is in that
it's exactly like
the prequels the d agent is great yeah
that's what i mean like it's it's like
he just steps straight out of that movie
it's good they play that stuff in the
wides and with a lot of motion too the
empire will attack soon
they're stronger than us better equipped
better trained if we try and fight them
we will not survive oh that's bad news
we just need to hold them off long
enough to get you all out broken how
much time do you need to override the
doors three four hours you have one
we're going to lock down every other
entrance in this facility if we defend
our position together
then by the time they get inside we'll
be gone that's the general kenobi we
know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh of course
[Music]
music is on fire this episode
[Music]
that was underwhelming
i'm going to need a ladder it's not
playtime right now princess do she asks
i trust her get her the ladder that's
the daughter of vader right there you do
what she says
if i don't hear from you soon i'll head
to tatooine
i pray you're safe i'll be well
you also pray your daughter's safe
[Music]
you're right ben
some things you can't forget
but you can fight to make them better
we're in trouble
that's like the theme of everything he's
been doing pretty much
tell the inquisitor i want to talk
i'll buy as much time as i can
[Music]
if this is you stalling for time
lord vader will have you at any cost
[Music]
you mean anakin
you knew who vader was
vader would have kept that hidden
unless you were there the night of order
66 you were a young one
anakin killed the others that's enough
he killed the other young ladies somehow
enough damn it's a revelation
when he left
i played dead
um
they were the only family i knew
and he slaughtered them
you are not serving your mind
don't need
anyone
you won't stop him alone
you have no idea
what i've done alone
cool oh
oh go
wow
that was a cool shot
oh
it's a dog fight
[Music]
you goddamn stormtroopers
[Music]
no dope oh no
tala i like you
[Music]
guys hold on yeah
oh nice nice
loader droid mvp
no
yeah it was coming
and he's done too
yeah no hold on
oh that sucks
[Music]
[Music]
oh
my shield
[Music]
don't close the door on him
oh god oh wow
[Music]
inquisitor has breached the walls we
shall have him soon
tell her to stand down
my lord
kenobi is already ours
[Music]
damn and they are just as good with the
the fighting i'm going back are you
gonna fight without a weapon
there are other ways to fight
no
okay we've been looking for such a long
time leah he's on his way
you're gonna die soon
you're not bringing him to me
i'm bringing him to you
hmm
there are families back there
children
are you going to let him do it again
what he did to you
what makes you think
he won't see it coming
because all you see is me
that blind rage
[Music]
got all the hissing and crackling still
so good at that [ __ ] damn sounds amazing
your weapon's gone
your need for victory anakin it blinds
you
oh [ __ ]
i have him secured inside my lord i will
bring him in myself
[Music]
give me back my lightsaber come on guys
give me back my lightsaber
there it
[Music]
in here is
[Music]
much
[Music]
i do love the way they captured darth
vader
absolutely imposing mark he is the
imperial march yeah
[Music]
damn you did it leia gotta get on that
[ __ ] you found that button
[Music]
oh you know he's gonna find that
he's so badass
oh
i had a feeling it was going to do that
i was like he's strong enough to do that
oh damn dead ass oh
that's so great we're
i think it's a decoy right
oh
oh
oh my god yes
yeah
you stop that one two vader he could
have but it was too late i had a feeling
he was gonna do that
hey
you're a great warrior anakin
but you need to prove yourself as your
undoing
until you overcome it
that's the saber
[Music]
damn these were the prequel scenes i
wanted
so good
hmm
[Music]
i think she's about to get stabbed yeah
[Music]
oh
he was wise to use you against me
uh
oh god damn
oh
[ __ ]
oh my god i love it that's so good
holy crap
no saber
it's like kung fu master
oh my god oh
cool
oh
yes come on reva get a good one in at
least no way at least take a piece with
you
oh my god oh this is amazing oh no
[Music]
oh is he gonna pull it oh okay oh
looky there
pick it up
he literally said
let's go
one on one
[Music]
oh oh my god
he's so good
it's so crispy man that was awesome dude
the flow i'm sorry i feel sorry for reba
but damn
oh man
wow you see the child in her eyes right
there yeah
that's a bummer man
did you really believe i did not see it
youngling
damn
jungling huh
various photos
it was a master plan this whole time
we will leave you where we found you
in the gutter
where you belong
goodbye
where's he been hiding probably in a
back to tank he was like i'm just
waiting for my moment
when the inquisitors stand by walking
any moment
damn i don't give a [ __ ] what people say
man that was one of the coolest
live-action vader scenes that was
everything
that was that was one of the coolest
maybe the coolest that was like in terms
of fighting yeah
it man like the way he was dodging
[Music]
ah
get your tattooing man
[Music]
wow damn
that was a cool episode whoo-hoo
stanton co-wrote this i really like that
one i love that one how we all feeling
good man that was great huh
yeah that's between attack of the clones
and clone wars or is that like the
mystic clone wars you think
um
that's around clone wars yeah yeah i
like how that one fight kind of
resembled this whole plot that we were
watching unfold between the two of them
playing games with each other trying to
outwit each other here
ah so sick
it could be it could be pre-clones era
too though
um it's definitely around that time
though because because clone wars starts
with attacker clone so it could be
probably
pre-clones
era right before yeah i got my
little interest up yeah
pre-attack of the clones that's what i
mean yeah yeah
damn
yeah man that was fun it was cool seeing
hayden right yeah it was oh i loved it i
loved seeing hayden what really dawned
on me
would hit me this time around something
that the prequels never did for me
is it was the first time seeing
you know i kind of said this before with
other episodes but this one especially
did it for me was
seeing hayden christensen
it was the first time like that is young
darth vader like that's the first time
i've ever felt that young darth vader
whereas before it was
kind of like i have a very different
association with the prequels versus
original trilogy sure and here i felt
like nah that this is hayden christensen
embodying young darth vader at this
point and
i really i really thought he was great
here and even those little bits we got
but
you know riva is terrible at sneaking up
on vader what a stupid ass way to sneak
up on vader you don't yell and get a big
ass strike ready to go you just do you
should do the kylo ren stab thing that
remember in the last jedi
that's what you do to vader you don't
[ __ ]
charge up and yell
stupid
no idea contained within the last jedi
is good and i'm offended that you would
recommend that
i mean i just the fact that they uh just
whatever you think about reeva's uh
character portrayal um
i mean i really like i really liked her
a lot in this episode everything just
kind of just really clicked for me
especially with uncovering her backstory
yeah
it's always been kind of like a little
bit
a lot of people have been predicting
that she'd probably turn good by the
or somehow fight on obi-wan's side by
the end um
however i uh her character just did come
full like full circle and the whole
performance kind of came full circle to
me yeah in this one episode when you
uncover that like
every every bit of your portrayal now
makes a lot more sense
it definitely makes sense because it's
it's one of those things where
it wouldn't make sense if she was a
young glee
that she knew anakin was vader and that
she would join vader yeah that's what
would bug me it kind of bugged me when i
that's when episode two came out
and she was like anakin is vader and i
was like uh
why would you like him
if he killed like
everyone you know yeah and it made a lot
more sense for me for her to to not
be with that yeah
he groomed her
yeah he says
that's where we've come to is one major
franchise to comment on another major
franchise
that's the kind of allegory that we
really need the hard-hitting stuff man
yeah
just awful jokes people
all right well let's talk about this but
wait a second
thanks to storyblocks
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is quite affordable they
have multiple subscription levels to
suit your exact needs whether you're an
independent indie solo creator or a
whole team so if you want to learn more
head on down to our link in the
description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video
all right yeah um this was an amazing
episode i i genuinely love this one i'll
get my one little nitpick out of the way
my my little
i mean
i think it's kind of a valid criticism
when the people of this planet what's
this planet called jimbo japan
is good
uh
yeah was we know when they're all in
danger and everyone's going all general
on their ass um about like we gotta
we're gonna here's what we're gonna do
i was just there going man i don't know
[ __ ] about you people i don't give a
crap die
i don't i don't i don't i just didn't
they haven't done anything to make me
feel invested in them sure
i i think
just the whole like they're families
there's kids i think that was the main
it's a universal thing we can all get on
board yeah that's it families and kids
that's my one little thing all right but
i didn't come here to watch obi-wan to
learn about the people of japanese so i
don't really care about the notions of
japanese yeah so i don't really care
about it um but as far as this episode
went uh this is my favorite one of of
the seasons so far i thought it was uh
firing on pretty much all cylinders for
me i loved the music all around
um but the way they use the fight scene
between anakin and obi-wan
of the the lessons learned in that fight
and then watching it kind of repeat
itself you know of the vader's mistakes
of going head-on for just so determined
to get victorious
and you know obi-wan being able to
anticipate the way vader is because he
knows that anakin is still so much in
there i thought was awesome but god damn
it all right look look what's the real
thing here the real thing is that
[ __ ] fights
when freaking vader shows up and to stop
the and he stops the ship i just love
the way it was captured because
it's so reactionary the way he does it
he just walks through that door the
second he sees the ship he just lifts it
because the way they capture vader here
with the cool handheld and that like his
march in in this show was just such a
imposing force no pun intended but such
an imposing force
then he when the way he grabs his ship
it felt like something out of you know
other like as we were talking about in
between um
you know when we cut the camera like how
you were saying is it's that's the kind
of vader that's usually captured in
other mediums you know to me i'm like oh
that's like the video game baiters i
love it
and and then of course the fight scene
too you know you're pointing out man i'm
just gonna point out things they said
and why you're here bud but notice like
that classic kung fu master kind of
fight scene of i'm not gonna really i'm
just gonna use defense against you you
know not even going to strike you just
move my body in and away move like water
ah it was it was it was awesome and and
uh revo went up a lot of points and uh
you know how much of a dick would i be
if i let may john talk first while he's
fixing his microphone
he's how do you go ahead absolutely it
was it was awesome man it was really
cool to see as you said when we were
saying when we were off camera the idea
of vader being the most powerful force
user which means that he uses
the way he uses the force is so unique
and so different and he uses his
offensively as well as defensively
versus someone like obi-wan who uses a
lot of force pushes and stuff like that
where vader uses it as like
using the saber against you pulling down
ships ripping apart ships ripping doors
apart like we don't really see that too
much in star wars medium at least live
action on film yeah so seeing vader do
that was really cool it was really cool
to see him like use the force to almost
sense movement before they come right
where he could see kind of like in you
know they explain what the forces you
can see moments before they happen you
can see the future briefly so it's like
he's dodging those shots that riva's
going for
using the force and he's doing it so
easily because he's so tapped into the
dark side of the force that it's like
this is second nature to him
um it's awesome it's like uh i'm telling
you man it's like it's like a basketball
player with like
sweet handles who's just like schooling
you he's just like bro come at me
it's so cool if i ever am blessed with
any kind of sport career i want sweet
handles
kyrie with the handles or steph curry
with the handles jay helms yeah i
thought this was great this this felt
like i was watching an episode out of
the series i was hoping for all along uh
you know not to slight what's come
before because i've enjoyed stuff out of
every other episode but this was the one
that felt like yeah it was firing on the
most cylinders all at once and it felt
like the desperation clicked and one
thing that i especially appreciated that
i noticed partway through was when riva
and vader were fighting
and i know how everyone feels about riva
but for me i was sitting there going
come on land a good blow get something
up on him and and it and it had me in
that place where i was like
something could happen even though in
the back of my mind i know that vader's
gonna go on and we're gonna get all four
five and six and all sorts of other
stuff with darth vader and darth vader's
definitely not going to perish here and
now
at the same time i was caught up in the
moment to that degree and i feel like
that you know feeling of peril and that
actual just sort of um the way that that
can transport you into just the
immediate here and now of an episode
like this i think is really effective
and yeah uh this
kind of coalesced to where like yeah
there are still certain
aspects of character especially with
obi-wan i wish we could have dived into
this that brought a lot of at least
nice sort of lyrical nods to the pa you
get that one flashback that's sort of
the wraparound of everything that's kind
of underpinning the emotion of this
episode but i feel like through those
glimpses and the way you were talking
about the force almost giving you these
brief glimpses into the future i like
the way that you could also compare it
to ptsd but the way they used brief
flashes from the past in these present
moments uh either between uh riva and
vader or just vader improaching um
imposing and approaching uh obi-wan and
the rest of the uh you know sort of
cobbled together rebellion like i
thought that yeah this
managed to sweep me up and then with all
the visuals and the music you know it
came together to feel like yeah this is
definitely like the best episode thus
far and yeah like it's a good episode of
this series but it's also a good episode
of you know the the
the series that we've been kind of
speculating on in the previous episodes
when we've been discussing what hasn't
clicked so much for us so i'm i'm really
happy to see that they got there uh here
well what i've been what i really
appreciate about this one too is that
you saw obi-wan
because we we've been expecting this for
him to kind of morph back into
you know being in tomb of the force
being a you know lightsaber user again
being a jedi overall but here we got to
see him be a general again which is
something that i was very much
appreciative of
um
and i think what they do that's really
interesting and really a lot was just
kind of clicking for me this episode is
because obi-wan is not really known
to i mean and correct me if i'm way off
base here but from my recollection he's
not he's not want to just start telling
people like everything that's going on
internally with him you know he you know
i think about something like with
duchess a teen even for example like it
took him forever to kind of divulge his
feelings for her and he it usually takes
a specific type of intimate moment for
him to say how he's thinking and feeling
even in this episode you see when he at
the at the final moments you know he's
like everything's fine guys everything's
fine i don't think anything's wrong
but then you have that look i think a
lot of what the turmoil of the of ob one
or even mcgregor's performance here is
mainly done with these like really
intimate handheld close-ups on his like
eyes and face when he's just
lost in thought over a particular
situation but he usually covers up when
he's around other people depending on
you know who he's like comfortable with
or depending on the moment so i i feel
like kind of those emotional meets that
you're sort of hoping to get a little
bit more of it as am i i think that's
really going to come in the final
episode i'm hoping god damn am i hoping
i'm really hoping that it's the final
episode of whatever conversation we get
i hope it's not just another cool fight
with vader and obi-wan that whatever
dialogue exchange they have
and and i'm i'm kind of hoping that like
and and you know darth vader takes off
the helmet or something like that where
we can have the conversation without the
helmet you know because it is kind of
cool
every once in a while i get pulled out
going obi-wan saying vader even
mcgregor's obi-wan is saying the word
vader and i don't think he's never this
is the first time he's gonna even say
the word vader before was in this show
so
yeah yeah man that was this is great
because i think the
i think this one was a very like a
really good composed stage they set for
like having the locked off section of
where everyone is
and
man [ __ ] star wars has this
incredible ability to fool me for a few
moments to make me think storm troopers
are cool again you know when they're all
like lined up
cool they look cool they look really
cool and it was a cool
like you said like set direction where
you have all the storm troopers lined up
you have the ship in the back and then
you have riva walk in right through the
middle you have vader walked right
through the middle it felt like it felt
very cinematic it felt it felt very
cinematic and that was a really cool
aspect of this episode that probably
wasn't done previously too much in the
previous ones
um
i i just i really enjoyed that and even
the fights i don't know we haven't
talked about a little bit about the
fight scene beforehand with the storm
troopers in obi-wan
yeah slightest simplicity of it yeah
yeah it was really cool because they
take it away man it felt like
this was kind of like a throwback to
like you're facing down like 40
stormtroopers at once and here's a jedi
in the middle of it just taking down
like
dozens of them just by their own blaster
fire yeah well i think the
the
slight difference is because what this
episode really demonstrated was this
variation of lightsaber fights
you know the the fight scene between
riva and vader is very different than
the one that obi-wan and anakin were
having in their flashback which felt
very much like out of the prequel fights
and by the way again hayden christensen
and ewan mcgregor like oh god damn you
guys can still move like
even better in some ways you know yeah
it was awesome it felt ripped right out
of attacking the clones yeah i felt like
oh my god i'm back in 2010 it was
awesome sitting in theater 10 years old
but even when um
when they are fighting the storm
troopers you know a lot of times when
they're deflecting
if this is just on our podcast we have a
podcast by the way which is on the
podcast it's just dude like that but i
love whenever he did like a full-on
strike you know to deflect the laser i'm
like i don't know you don't really see
that too often with the jedi um doing a
full-on like baseball strike or a sword
strike uh to to get a laser away um but
john you're your homie girl she died
this episode
i'm sorry man i know i'm i i'm very very
sorry oh
yeah yeah
i was like justice for tala man i mean
hey she got a good those moments always
really work well on me when there's like
some kind of moment of
clarity or moment of uh
just
piercing through the veil of chaos you
know and and that moment i thought was
very effective and yeah i figured she
would probably be sacrificed especially
because i think of the morality
uh not to say that there's one uniform
to it but i think the morality of of
something like this you know in order
for her to have worked her way up the
imperial ladder she must have had i mean
she talks about it here she's done some
pretty nasty things and so i think
that's the ultimate poetic end for a
character like that is to have them go
out in some kind of benevolent sacrifice
and yeah even that like
i i really enjoyed her journey over this
and i thought they made a moment out of
that in a really nice way and that when
uh leia when leia comes down and she's
like you know where's tala did tala make
it like you know that that even rang
true to me uh uh for as much as you know
again we've sort of gone back and forth
about how they've characterized
characters like yeah i thought they
characterized her she was one of the
highlights of the series for me and i'm
very sad to see her go
yeah and i mean it was it was nice to
get more of that supporting cast into so
it starts to feel like a bit of a
community because you have her and you
have uh um
rokin and you have hajja back and you
know you've got some familiar faces to
at least pin it together and i'm glad
that
at least you know they made it out you
know we might be able to see some of
them in the future i do wish though that
we got yeah like
sometimes and i think we've had this
issue we've i think we've all kind of
shared this
uh complaint before
with this show
is sometimes i'm like just take a little
bit more of them i mean maybe down the
heat of the moment but when you're back
on the ship you know like them grieving
tala like them really feeling the loss
of
someone like that especially leia in in
that given situation and then someone
and something that really
like hit me that was so sad
was her the droid remember the droid's
name jordan
lola
no not lola the loader troll oh the
loader droids yeah when the droid died
it was as like a shield yeah it was so
like
so dramatic and yeah he just fell to his
knees like i'm here to protect you in
your last moments yeah like oh man i
wish we got more of a
i felt sad but i'm like if we got a
little bit more of that dynamic with
them i would have been heartbroken it
was very much a k2 moment definitely
one yeah great great call that's why
you're here to say [ __ ] like that
that's what it felt very much like they
were trying to tell us that to
communicate this is a k2
moment well i thought they did a good
job imbuing that droid with personality
and i just could have used more of that
up until here yeah like it would have it
it affected me but it could have been
that much more affecting yeah what was
your favorite parts about this man um
i really like you know what i thought
was cool and and i might be wrong and i
and maybe it's because i had one heart
phone in here your subjective opinion is
wrong
but i i i don't hear everything all the
way through but when when obi-wan was
like let me talk to her
i think the storm trooper went up to
riva and he's like well this one's gonna
negotiate and i was like oh my god
obi-wan the negotiation the negotiator
yeah
oh crap he's gonna do the thing he's
gonna negotiate because he's the
negotiator
uh
i thought that was cool i thought that
was a cool call back to like obi-wan
being the guy to like
try to talk his way out of her into a
situation he did it in clone wars he
does it in uh various clone wars
episodes but he doesn't in clone wars
movie but even uh general grievous calls
him the negotiator because he's supposed
to be really good at not manipulating
but kind of manipulating a situation
where he's able to talk his way into or
out of situations
uh with of enemies or villains or people
that he can try to you know
get to do certain things that they
didn't want to do and vader hinted at
that at the end of the episode when he
told riva he's like yeah you know
obi-wan knows what he's doing when he
told you those things and stuff like
that where i was like oh okay so they're
kind of hinting at
obi-wan being able to use not just
anakin's rage but riva's rage
to escape
uh and i was like that's a cool call
back to obi-wan
doing his clone wars general kenobi
thing so yeah that was one of my
favorite moments that's a great that was
that's actually that didn't even dawn on
me at the moment yeah that's a great
call because
yeah it's usually like obi-wan is even
even a lot of time it's
sometimes the negotiation is just a uh
is it it's the decoy it's a distraction
yeah well like etiquette and ahsoka are
going in and handling that's kind of
what it was that's kind of what it was
here too like all right well i'm
actually kind of like buying you guys
some time while i'm negotiating my way
out of here oh yeah yeah way to go ex
you proved your worth for being here
positive comments only
um i love this one i thought it was
excellent and i want to say like you
know reba's
you guys have been way more positive
about riva than i've been way more back
and forth about um uh moses ingram's
performance
and
i've always liked her subtle scenes more
like the scene when her and obi-wan are
on the other side other side of the door
and they're talking to each other
and [ __ ] like that one i'm like this
should have been a bin show because you
know a lot of those complaints that
people talk about i'm like it's all
dressed here when people are like
throwing their arms a bit very like how
does she know
like yeah i just waited a little bit
would have got the answer two episodes
here and i don't know it's a more avid
star wars fan does that answer like
bother you at all no not at all i mean
to me
it
what bothered me i said it after the
episode was the idea that
she was a youngling who saw anakin
slaughter all the other young liens
and then she was like i'm gonna follow
this guy who's vader like that would
have bothered me way more than this
description because to me that made no
sense for someone to be traumatized by
someone and then to suddenly be like but
i'm devoted to them because they're
powerful and i'm just like but no
that wouldn't make any sense i mean i
could see a scenario depending on how
you raise someone there's a lot of
[ __ ] up french films you need to watch
i mean i feel like killing thousands of
children
star wars really needs a little more of
a new wave vibe to it depraved human
drama elements i just feel like someone
killing thousands of oh no no okay
you're talking about something very
logical i'm talking about a very
different type of sure sure like
fear-based thing and well i mean it does
make me kind of question you know why he
spared her
and you know what was their relationship
ultimately like you know it would make
more sense if it was like i spare you
and i kind of morph you into like my
uh daughter's padawan thing but you know
like something but it seems it still
seems like the relationship is so
impersonal though it doesn't feel like
there's anything
um more to grasp on to other than
because i would have never picked up
that there was some type of
bigger history with these two
other than that's an inquisitor
auditioning for the grand inquisitor
you know and and i think that's part a
quality that i just think that would
have added more nuance and weight if if
they did kind of allude to
there's a reason he's because they
didn't even go into that you know why
out of like all the young links he
doesn't kill her unless i totally missed
it in the heel at the moment and yeah
yeah cause looking at the visual
language of that scene it sure looked
like he stabbed her through both times
so i'm like did he just leave her for
dead and she didn't die or or terrible
yeah because in that moment it sure
looked like they tried to do a match
shot where yeah anakin blue lightsaber
stabs her
vader red lightsaber same thing
i think the implication
i'm gonna reach here but you know this
is what i do
uh that's why we pay you the columns
michael jordan
uh but i i think the implication and
maybe it's just that one line that vader
had when he says you didn't think i see
this coming where i feel like maybe the
implication was his he was always
planning on using her somehow like this
is a tool for me to get somewhere
in the future
um the sith do seem the least skeeved by
being like hey i know you got a lot of
rage and you probably hate me but we can
work with that yeah it's very much like
i can see certain things coming but
earth only to a certain point but i
could still see them coming where the
implication of the dark side users see
in the future is very much like
i can see what i can do with this person
i can see the potential
this far in distance and i feel like
maybe that's what riva was to vader
where he's like um this girl is gonna
take me somewhere she's gonna do
something for me i'm gonna keep her
around
you know keep her close manipulate her
make her seem like she's powerful
give her titles or pretend to give her
titles and do all this kind of stuff in
order to get what i need to get yeah uh
no i i think that's
i think sure that's definitely there uh
i mean it shows especially in the text
of keeping the grand inquisitor alive
and putting up this false thing of
having people compete for grand
inquisitor i still think that there's
still some i don't know i mean it's a
bit
of a reach in the sense i'm like well if
he can kind of predict that far down the
road why didn't he he could have
predicted how the [ __ ] could have gone
down with uh obi-wan
on uh oh my god i'm like moose
oh you mean in uh revenge of this yeah
yeah because that's that was obviously
before that fight with obi-wan so i
don't know i mean but i feel like in
that moment it was more like
if you re-watch revenge of the sith it's
super like he's he's just all blind rage
church even his eyes are yellow and he's
screaming all the time and he's like you
you are lost and he's like
and it feels like anakin in that moment
is just like so consumed by the dark
side and so consumed with the dark deeds
that he did yeah during that time that
it's like i don't think he can see
anything except like red
except yeah when he was slaughtering
younglings a very optimistic personality
at the time
very positive thinking
this slaughter is going bad
this is an a grade slaughter if i say so
myself guys
i i still love seeing
the 501st there
uh anakin's uh
on the first episode
no the 501st is anakin's own clone oh
yeah
yeah um which i think is funny because
if you follow the clone wars
um animated series they're like the the
homies they're like the cool we're like
the cool guys and then they slaughter
all the child
and it's like damn i thought you guys
were cool wasn't uh wasn't the tamara
morrison boba fett
not in beaufort but it's more morrison
that was 501st one right yeah
well [ __ ] all right guys well yeah um if
i was going with the whole riva point i
thought she did a great job in this
episode um i really liked her a lot and
i think that i'm i'm very hope i'm
holding now i hope that this this next
one's going to stick to landing and i
hope it's not [ __ ] like 35 minutes or
whatever the [ __ ] this length has been
because this this felt it was about the
same length as the last episode yet this
felt way more substantial it did yeah i
think it was a little maybe like five
five or six minutes longer maybe but
still i could go for a full hour yeah i
agree
i still feel like there stood could be a
little bit more time to breathe yeah
like give me give me five more minutes
to let certain scenes breathe this is
paced really well for a show that is
mostly concerned with plotting yes uh
or i'll say well pretty well for a show
mostly concerned with plotting i
sometimes wish it was a show concerned
with more than plotting to a greater
extent well that's why i'm kind of
thinking that the first episode was more
emotional and then i'm hoping the last
episode you know kind of brings it full
circle with making it more emotional
d if
i'm hoping i'm not saying that well
i'm hoping is is it the kind of thing
where one episode if that last episode
is just
so what you've been hoping for that it
would make the entire series feel like a
smooth ride or would it be kind of like
we we got there by the end i mean
writing something to be episodic is very
different than writing something to be
binge and i know that when they write
this [ __ ]
they write it as one piece as like one
one big piece and then they go but we're
gonna release it weekly
and there's just such a different type
of writing formula to that so
you know i i'm that's kind of the hope
that i'm having is that oh yeah that one
this is all out i could re-watch all
this in one sitting and be like yeah
it's one big package this is great
um yeah i still feel like but you know
like the little five extra minutes
you're talking about will go a long way
in situations like the things i was kind
of craving a little bit more of an
emotional nuance of uh absolutely but
hey this is fun this is great hi
good job on pointing out things we
didn't notice ace that's what you're
here for killing it ace for for sure
that's not like
exceptionally consumed with easter eggs
too surprisingly i don't feel like it's
like it's cons i feel like mandalorians
like really like
[Music]
fingerprints are all over that [ __ ] so i
think that's why that shows
solo as cool as easter eggs are
seeing
a coruscant flashback with anakin and
ob1 that that just that fight scene the
dialogue the fight
that whole thing just made the episode
worse yeah it was beautiful it made
everything worth it because it was cool
to see
hayden christensen is anakin skywalker i
don't know if we've mentioned that too
much but
seeing him as anakin
and seeing him take on that personality
take on even the same fighting form and
i know that's a really really nerdy
thing but the fighting formed and you're
not the only one who's gonna pick that
up uh and the fighting form that that
obi-wan has which is form two a very
defensive form i think anakin's form
five
uh you know you sound like a [ __ ]
idiot
which is an offensive
you know very aggressive form and it
kind of
as as nerdy as that is that that's kind
of what the whole thing is about right
it's about defense and often it's about
what what do you take and what do you do
when you're facing a situation when
you're
fighting each other you know how do you
battle and that's why obi-wan says you
don't have to battle with just weapons
and aggression you can battle in
different ways yeah
that was cool that made the whole
episode worth it
that's me being real tired
you can battle in the comments um
yeah no i full heartily agree with all
that um absolutely and hannah
christiansen that scene is more i know
you're much bigger
i like attacking the clones
i like attacking the clones and i love
revenge of the sith and you know what's
funny is normally the hate train goes
phenomenal [ __ ] that but but attacking
the clones is all right um that's like
that's my guilty pleasure and i'm
actually the opposite i'm like i like
attack of the clones and i really don't
like phantom menace but i really love
revenge of the sith and john's favorite
movie is phantom that's right number one
star wars just all movies in general
yeah
my top three is phantom menace phantom
menace and phantom men it's something
josh anchor and then shawshank
redemption which i haven't seen but i'm
just going to trust that it's my fourth
favorite movie when i do see it
and then phantom menace phantom menace i
just like to look at
what's he thinking i love him
how is this bit going
it's going great is it good is there
enough love for the prequels in the bit
perfect the mountain you like your mic
all right i love my mic what's your
ranking what's your ranking of the three
goals
what's your ranking of the prequels
my ranking of the prequels yeah oh
that's tough
phantom menace phantom menace phantom
menace i'd probably go revenge of the
sith and then phantom menace
and then attack of the clones wow that's
the wrong order
revenge of the sith number one how that
doesn't make any sense i'm pretty sure
that's universal
i should have you do a ranking video
here on the channel tonight i love i
love all three though to be honest i i
think they're all different for
obviously for what they're trying to
communicate
but they all have different aspects and
they all have their own like pros and
cons true because a lot of people are
like phantom menace is dumb because of
jar jar and i'm like yeah but
but attacking the clones has like really
weirdish dialogue sometimes and i feel
like that kind of is a drawback
and then
but yeah but phantom menace i feel like
with phantom menace though is that what
feminism does so well it's qui-gon
and dorothea and i feel like those two
things just make it like
bump up in my list so when in the next
episode do you think we'll see qui-gon
when they're fighting next step
is going to break it up
he's like whoa whoa whoa he does the
chris pratt jurassic park
yeah oh my god that would be good
that'd be better if they just had chris
pratt
dinosaur he's like i don't know where i
am
he's like whoa he's blue
clicker train all these sith and jedi
really quick all right guys what did you
think about this episode thank you so
much for being here
um and thank you to storyblocks for
sponsoring this video last but not least
and thank you to ace follow ace on
social media last but not least let's do
a patreon
all right michael linden john really
wanted to shout you out it's john
mchale listen okay this is why i want to
shout you out because at first i was
like uh who in their patreon could be an
inquisitor easily you could be
you know you're already very angelo and
you've got you know the specs you know
you've got a kind of intense look about
you so you could be some kind of sith
inquisitor but then i started to think
man
mikhail you could be anybody in the star
wars universe i can imagine you as you
know a very wise um but very
conscientious jedi i could even imagine
you as a youngling you know in the
temple maybe escaping before order 66
happens biding your time finding the
remnants of the jedi displaced across
the galaxy and aiding them and bringing
back the glory of the resistance michael
you could be
an alien of the star wars universe you
don't even have to go and keep your own
you know visage you could be you know
using some kind of advanced tech to hide
what you look like to blend in on our
earth because what little do we know we
exist in the galaxy far far away the
possibilities mikhail are ndls and i
appreciate that your support for us too
is endless and that you have maintained
your focus your oneness with the force
of our patreon that you are still here
and you're still being as supportive and
loving as ever which is why you could
never be a sith inquisitor see we're
going full circle because there's not
enough hate and chaos and anger
unrequited unchecked unanswered inside
your heart to allow it to rot to that
degree so mikhail thank you
for choosing the light side and for
sticking with us and we'll see you next
month
damn wow you say a lot of [ __ ] man damn
bars let's turn to slam poetry what
happened was i wha i blacked out for a
minute you killed it bro you killed it
and now chopping bars yeah man dude that
was great
dude yes because we've all earned a shot
of patron tonight patron
patrolman
yeah all right yeah i think we did it
yeah essay but you did it you did it
essays
[Applause]
[Music]